two years ago when the coronavirus sent
people into intensive care they were
often the only thing between life and
death I'm talking about nurses the
pandemic it may be ending but the plight
of these essential men and women it is
not today in parts of the UK nurses
staged an unprecedented strike it's the
first time that the Royal College of
nurses Trade union has called a strike
in its 106 year history
up to a hundred thousand nurses walked
off the job on Thursday they say that
this is a last resort in their fight for
better wages and better working
conditions union leaders say that nurses
are overworked due to short staffing and
that's exasperated by a backlog of
appointments and treatments made worse
by the coronavirus pandemic
here's the head of the nurses Union
followed by the British Health minister
I would love
to get anything but pay they closed
their books don't put an extra Brown to
Penny on the table and they walk away
and they turn the back up they're back
on the profession we have an independent
process that looks
these issues in Iran that looks at the
pressure for many viewers are faced with
higher taxes facing costs of living
pressures and balances those with the
needs of our NHS as well and that
independent pay review looks at these
issues and we have accepted their
recommendations in full
I'm joined Now by Howard cat and he is
the CEO of the international Council of
nurses he joins me from Geneva Mr Canton
it's good to have you on the show you
know I want to ask you we reported so
much on the nurses in the UK when the
pandemic started that the worst phase of
the pandemic and it was the nurses who
were the essential workers that people
were praising they were a godsend to
many people how is it possible that in
the span of two years we go from that to
a hundred thousand nurses striking
because they can't even get a proper pay
increase
uh good evening
um this is an issue in the UK it's a
global issue we have seen uh during the
share from the summer an increase in
disputes and in strike action right the
way around the world and there are some
striking similarities in terms of What's
led us to this point
um we have had a historic undervaluing
of the nursing profession right the way
around the world we hear the words of
care of compassion of a vocation but
that's almost been an excuse not to pay
nurses fairly and properly as you say
the pandemic then comes along and
everybody sees the true value of nurses
and nursing care holding our communities
holding our societies together we got on
our doorsteps and we applaud the work
that our nurses and our healthcare
workers have done but as we move on from
the pandemic that Applause hasn't
translated into to any action quite the
opposite the UK are digging in we're not
even going to talk to the nursing
leaders about pay so that Applause
without action has led to understandable
anger but there's one other really
important Point that's at the heart of
what the nurses in the UK are saying and
around the world this is a patient
safety issue we don't have enough nurses
we can't provide safe high quality
Health Care Services well you and your
organization the international Council
of nurses you've written to the UK
government you're calling for more
investment in it Healthcare are you
saying if things continue the way they
are that going into a clinic going into
a hospital if if you're if you're sick
you may be actually putting your life in
your health in danger by doing that
oh I think the shortages that we have in
healthcare right now already uh present
a risk to patient care but the reason we
wrote to the health minister in the UK
is because we have this narrative which
is we can't afford to pay nurses uh you
know we've got difficult Economic Times
we've got war in Europe we pay nurses
inflation is going to go up this is
wrong thinking we need to flip 180
degrees how we look at Health Care not
as a cost but as an investment as I've
said when Healthcare goes wrong our
societies our communities start to
crumble but we also know when we
Healthcare goes right people are healthy
they work they're productive it's a
driver for economic growth and if we
invest in health workers in our Health
Care Systems in the research and the
innovation Mission we firmly believe
that the road to economic growth is
paved by investment in health and that's
the argument that we are trying to make
to all governments around the world yeah
and your argument is a valid one but you
know even Even in our program today you
know I'm reporting about
um a 16 17 year old player in Brazil who
plays soccer and he's now being
transferred you know for millions and
millions of dollars that speaks to the
priorities our society has right now
Millions for soccer players not Millions
for nurses I wonder how you change that
because I think we're talking about
something here that goes beyond
Appropriations and budgets
I think you're right I think there's a
much deeper issue about how we value
different workers and what's important
to us as societies you know the the
irony around these strikes is that just
a few months ago we were saying to our
nurses and health workers you are the
most important people holding our
societies together but now we're saying
to them that uh they uh that if they're
going to go on strike we can't afford to
pay you we've got governments who are
driven by you know free market
principles the forces of supply and
demand but with 50 000 nursing vacancies
in the UK we think that we could be more
than 10 million nurses short globally as
well those free market principles would
tell you that pay is part of how you
recruit and retain but ministers Health
ministers politicians are turning their
back on why is that I think one of the
reasons why that may be I think there's
a gender issue going on here as well I
think you know my profession is 90 women
and the fact that you know we're not
looking at the Hard economics we're not
looking at the health security and
safety issues we're not looking at the
economic Arguments for investing in in
health why are our politicians turning
their back I think part of that could be
as I say because of the gender of well
the profession I I think too
unfortunately we're out of time Mr can
but yeah it's a valid argument I think
you could have this conversation talking
about school teachers talking about
police officers firefighters people that
we depend on you know for the essentials
and for some reason Society doesn't want
to pay them more than we know that they
they deserve but unfortunately we're out
of time Howard Canton with the
international Council of nurses thank
you we appreciate your time tonight
thank you